police in Moscow Idaho say they still
don't know who murdered four University
of Idaho students 12 days ago
investigators say they were attacked in
their sleep and are asking the
tight-knit community for help they're
also trying to quash rumors about the
killings Jonathan vigliati has more
with over 700 tips more than 100 pieces
of evidence 4 000 photos and expanded
search areas authorities still have no
suspects we still believe there's more
information to be gathered at a press
conference Wednesday moscow's police
chief issued another plea to the public
for any additional evidence from the
night of November 12th to the morning of
the 13th sometimes when a video or
picture doesn't show is equally as
important as what might be there the
location of the murder weapon a fixed
blade knife is still unknown police are
keeping details they do have under lock
and key including audio of the 9-1-1
call the names of the surviving
roommates and the names of those at the
house who spoke to dispatchers during
the call citing case Integrity the lack
of information is a pain point for
Kaylee consalves is already grieving
family we all want to play a part in
helping and we can't play a part if we
don't have any real substantial
information to work from detectives did
dispel rumors that the victims were tied
up and address claims that can solvez
had a stalker so far we have not been
able to corroborate it but we're not
done looking into that piece of
information City officers are pairing up
with state troopers and the sheriff's
department to step up patrols residents
of the community once considered safe
are now being warned to stay vigilant
Moscow has always been a very safe
community in some ways this took our
innocence for CBS this morning's
Jonathan Vigliotti